what kind of movie you're gonna make
[Music]
you dismissed what he does it's playful
or imaginative
you could afford to be a little
encouraging
what was your favorite part so
congratulations on the best home movie
ever made
everybody's gonna want one by the way
you're going to be solicited a lot to
make everybody else's story my first
question for you is how much of little
Steven showed up as a director when you
were making this film and are there any
techniques that young Steven still uses
today as a director
well you know whoever that guy was you
know I'm a different Stephen than I was
back then so I had to kind of remember
who I was in order to assemble this sort
of coming of age story but um I think
you know what showed up when I was
making the film was the Stephen that has
perspective so I what I brought to this
was memory and perspective
um that's why I didn't make this movie
30 40 years ago because I didn't have
the distance or even the wisdom of just
aging that gave me a kind of you know
courage to tell a story about my mom and
my dad and my sisters and and my my my
life has a as a sort of alien kid alien
to style you know you know kid and um
and you know so I think that you know I
would not have been able to have the
same objectivity that I'm able to have
today especially after my I lost my dad
lost my mom my mom died three years
before they're making the movie my dad
died only a year before began shooting
the film and being an orphaned as we all
eventually become you know gave me
really the impetus to go ahead and tell
the story now as opposed to a long time
ago you did revisiting your childhood in
that way give you new insights into
yourself as a filmmaker now just a fact
how much I love my mom and my dad and
this film probably was a beautiful thing
to bring my sisters and I uh even closer
together than we had ever been before
for you I read that you said the way in
part of the way into the character was
through Stephen's smile and I'm
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about that how you got the smile how you
nailed it and if you want to demonstrate
I'm not going to be mad at it
um I um well I I uh
I was nervous because I didn't feel like
I looked like him enough and I just
noticed that there are certain muscles
in his lip that move differently than
mine in how to smile so I watched a lot
of interviews and and and looked at a
lot of photos and then I thought well
this it's there's not a lot of
opportunity for him to be happy in this
movie it's very anxiety-inducing so then
I kind of decided Well what if he just
has an awkward smile when he's
uncomfortable and then that could be
enough that
um I look like him in the movie and uh
and and that's what I did I noticed the
posture there was a scene when you were
walking into the gym where the posture
was very much it was like little nuances
that I noticed
um was there a particular I know this
you've described it making this film as
being very cathartic
uh was there a particular moment
that you found sort of surprised you the
most in terms of what the emotions that
brought out in you well you know there
were many moments in in the telling of
the story that surprised me the most
especially in you know
at times in directing Michelle Williams
and and Paul dado my you know who are
playing my mom and dad there were times
when as they were
playing their characters
um I started seeing a lot of my mom and
dad in them and a couple of times I only
saw my mom and my dad and I had to snap
myself out of it actually you're a
director you need objectivity you know
you need that aesthetic distance between
the subject matter and your own point of
view and so I had to kind of force
myself to don't get lost don't it was
very indulgent if I was going to get
lost in a scene and start to see my mom
and my dad come back to life again so I
had to fight that a lot because they
were so good playing representing those
characters and and Gabe too you know
Gabe I gave Gabe a lot of access to home
movies family movies of myself and my
parents so he kind of really a member of
the family by the time we Shot the movie
One Last Question
um I want a sequel now I think people
always ask about sequels if you were to
film a sequel
um what stage of your life or filmmaking
career do you think you would make the
most interesting story to follow this
one up you know something I haven't
thought about that because there was so
much completion of kind of personal
Family Mission I had in in telling the
story so I haven't really given any
thought to how I would ever continue the
story because this whole experience has
really been cathartic for me and it's
really filled me up and I can't imagine
what that would be
Sammy's on my team takes after me
congratulations to the both of you an
extraordinary movie
um careers for both of you what's sort
of the most important conversation
that's or bit of information that
Stephen imparted to you about this
relationship between these two people
and their characters that was sort of
the most meaningful or sort of your way
in I you know I always I always think
about the first time that we spoke the
first Zoom that we had and I think for
both Paul and I we were it felt really
momentous to just even be on a screen
with this man but then so immediately he
dispels any nervousness that you might
have because he's so
um open-handed with his life with his
Recollections with his with the people
that he loved and so the we just
understood that we were being handed
something incredibly precious
I think we were
riding some wave of of memory and
learning and searching from him and he
was against so open and vulnerable
vulnerable with us that we just all kind
of tried to serve that together and
bring it to ultimately Burton Mitzi who
who are a version of Arnold and Leah I
want to talk to you about the dancing
scene it was such a that's sort of the
moment
that you know you talk about a character
defining moment or a moment that defines
a film and I really think that that was
so beautiful and I know that maybe you
said that was the bonding moment for all
of you on set that that camping scene
really gelled things but was that
improvised was that choreographed did he
let you be free
um how did that scene happen for you
both really it was both it was
I think I always feel like you really
have to you have to build something and
understand how it's made before you can
sort of take it apart and find a lot of
freedom in it so there was a dance that
was built and practiced and and and then
there was also just the moments and what
it was
um what it inspired you're also playing
an artist she was a true artist
so what sort of of yourself being an
artist yourself sort of gave way or so
what sort of kinship did you feel with
her so much and it sort of continues to
reveal itself honestly like I continue
to be moved by this woman who was an
artist and who lived her life and who
raised her children
um as though they were as though it was
Art itself
um and I think that that's something
that always really moved me about the
script is the creativity that was
um so uh that was everywhere in their
childhood you know you watch these home
movies and you see these photos and you
see the way that they lived and it was a
work of art it was and it gave way to
these four children
um who are all who who carry that
um you know not just even his three
sisters also have that spirit that like
that Lust For Life that um that their
mother and father gave them Paul for you
I know you talked a little bit about in
the past that there were three Stevens
on set there was Gabriel and then there
was Stephen now and sort of of the young
Stephen that came out can you talk a
little bit about how that that younger
Stephen how what you witnessed and and
well I think that the camping sequence
was I think three days and that is where
I personally really felt everything sort
of congeal and part of that was seeing
Stephen our leader one of the great film
artists of all time sort of go through
his own big experience and and really
share that with us which again opened
the door for everybody to just bring
everything they had but yes he wrote it
for him and Tony wrote it from the the
point of view of a child Wright Stevens
and then he's an adult man who's lived a
life and then he's the filmmaker and the
director trying to tell that story so it
was really interesting to watch him you
know sort of uh go through all those
different parts of himself I know um
a show on Earth being that it sort of
lit Steven's soul on fire to want to be
a filmmaker even though he didn't know
it at the time what was the film for
each of you the first
movie that you saw as a child that sort
of lit your soul on fire in terms of
maybe I want to be an artist myself
I don't know if it necessarily made me
think that I wanted to be an artist but
I it was maybe the first thing that I
recognized as art was The Sound of Music
we didn't really watch a lot and we
watched cartoons and
um you know sitcoms and stuff and and we
watched The Sound of Music so many times
and it
was being honest I think singing was
actually probably the the vessel that
got to the acting actually too
yeah yeah singing as a kid is such a
beautiful expression and I think that's
sort of what ended up well it's ecstatic
it's like when you when you can't speak
you sing and that like the the Resonance
of that and the the movement of that
like sort of from inside of you to
project it outside of you is like an
artistic trajectory so
um that movie yeah I guess like really
all those old musicals I think made me
feel
stirred I just love something you also
have to take care of it it's more
important than your hobby can you stop
calling it a hobby
I'm sure you had a lot of conversations
with Stephen
um he probably gave you a lot of a list
of films to watch you got to watch some
of his early films but what was the most
meaningful conversation or sort of like
clue in where you sort of thought oh I
got it I got this I have this character
aside from your brilliant audition
um it um
the big
the big aha moment was when I felt that
I got the smile down I I think that was
the really the big thing where I could
look in the mirror and feel like another
person and because Stephen and I had
been zooming for weeks and I've been
getting to know him and about his life
and his family and the script in this
character and I felt I'd been I I'd been
doing all that but
but I I really felt like
um another person when I when I could do
that how long did that take did you
practice in the meeting it took a few
days yeah in in the mirror for for
um a few hours I just watch uh a lot of
his his interviews and photos of him and
it was just that
I can't I can't even imagine and the
posture I noticed like was that
something you worked on well I I got to
watch a lot of his home uh movies of him
and his family and and I could see how
he walked as a kid back then he was very
um erect and he was he he led with his
chest and it's it's actually kind of
like
it reminds me of old like theater camps
learning how to walk on stage because
back then when he's a kid and and you
know he he's he's so stiff and and
upright and um his energy is all here
and this is how he leads
um out of this
false confidence if that's how you
should lead back when he when he was
that age but now
60 years later he still has great
posture but all of his energy is in his
hips it's much more grounded and real
and and an actual like uh authentic
confidence that you could just see him
walk it's it's you know like through set
and he has his Entourage of security and
he has his head down and he's thinking
and he has a cigar in his hand but he's
just like
swaying walking by so that's that was
really cool wow did he give you a camera
was there something about like you got
to learn a little bit about being
because you I imagine you would want to
know how to be a director to play an
aspiring director well I um this this
character is just
he he he just knows what looks good in a
in a camera he's not
um the movies he's making it's
he's still learning he's still learning
and so I you know he's not running a set
he has a camera and he has his friends
and
um which I could get to see with him and
Christy and and Tony and janish at times
because you have this
um there's there's almost this this this
assumption that huge blockbuster hits or
huge movies are are a bunch of people
around a table in suits like how do we
you know do this but with him it's him
and his friends with a camera
but just playing and and having fun and
that was super great to watch if there
was a film I know your character in the
film so
films
there was a set
a set in one of his previous movies that
you could have snuck on and then I'll
fly in the wall and sort of watch being
made what was what would be the movie it
would have to be I mean it has to be
Jaws I I to to if I was a fly on the
wall and nobody knew I was there I would
want to see the people Steven confides
his
fear of the shark not working I'd want
to see those moments because he's such a
great leader on set and and he's you
know he doesn't he he he steers the boat
and
um everybody feels very safe that
everything's working and I know that
that was a big struggle for him to do on
Jaws but I'd love to see those
conversations he has where he's venting
you stop making movies that'll break
your mother's heart I don't know what to
do anymore you do what your heart says
you have to so what is this I hear about
you so you snuck onto set 10 days early
just to sort of take away the sort of
Mystique of working with Stephen in the
nerves so tell me about showing up on
said early did anybody sort of say what
are you doing here no not at all I
didn't see God and I told him uh from
the first
you know when I I I I I I came up in a
very like insulated filmmaking
environment where I worked with a lot of
the same people throughout a lot of my
career and uh and we worked in what I've
learned it was a pretty specific way so
a lot of my questions to him when we
first talked were like how do you work
like how do you make a movie do you give
a lot of Direction not a lot of
direction do a lot of takes not a lot of
takes you know I have a friend who
worked with Clint Eastwood and they do
one take and it's like oh that's a whole
other way of working you know and so I
wanted to see uh yeah I wanted to just
demystify the process and I was like I
think I'll perform better for you if if
I can be there a lot and just see how
everything goes so by the time I'm
filming it's not like I'm I'm both
nervous about my performance and uh
struggling to comprehend kind of how you
work so
um and as a film fan it's just like if
you have an opportunity to be on a
Steven Spielberg set you take it and you
you take it as much as you can and you
don't leave and you you sit as close to
him as you can and you watch him and you
listen to him and that was something I
just wasn't going to pass up either so
it was like and he was thrilled to have
me there and always seemed happy that I
was there and
um was yeah so it was like uh it was a
beautiful beautiful experience I heard
that you did you like brought War the
worlds and you were like how did you
shoot this how did you shoot that please
give me one little secret or one little
tip about Steven Spielberg as a
filmmaker that you learned that you
would be willing to share he's always
like drawing his own little storyboards
on the which is not something a lot of
people do little scribbles all the time
and uh and then you look at them they
really it's like the shots as we're
doing it and they're very it looks like
a child drew them for the most part but
but they somehow translate into some
iconic filmmaking does it change the way
now that you've worked with him does it
change the way you go back and watch his
films when you watch his other films
where you sort of see a different see it
through a different lens
um I think one of the great things about
this movie honestly is it will do that
for everyone I think like
when you understand
the person who made so many iconic works
of art it gives those works of art an
entirely new meaning and you understand
why they did what they did in a new way
and why they made the choices they made
and and when it's someone as influential
as him what's interesting is you start
to see like oh these things that
affected him affected everyone including
you the viewer because we live in a
culture that has been shaped by him and
his sensibilities you know and so it's
really interesting to see you know the
kind of ripple effect of like oh if that
hadn't happened to him then like
action movies wouldn't be as popular as
they are today you know um it's like
yeah it's really interesting I want to
talk about the camping scene and sort of
filming those scenes with Michelle that
we're supposed to be those scenes that
Stephen was taking as a filmmaker that
he then pieced together later and put
together a secret that he unfolded like
when you were shooting those scenes with
Michelle sort of like the dip when you
sort of see your faces how subtle did
you have to be or how many times did you
sort of have to shoot those scenes to
sort of get that essence of what Stephen
was was going for Steven was operating
the camera himself in a lot of the eight
millimeter footage
um and uh which was also kind of surreal
so he kind of knew very he seemed to
know very specifically what he wanted I
don't remember doing like a ton of takes
of it like he we yeah I think he seemed
it seemed to go pretty smoothly and
pretty fast it was really interesting
always seeing him uh back there actually
filming it and sometimes they do it with
a uh you know Mitch the a camera
operator but they uh yeah it was those
were very surreal moments at times
because it really did sometimes feel
like we were just walking around the
woods with Steven Spielberg making a
whole movie I saw in a little home video
camera yeah
if you were to be Stephen's character in
this film sneaks onto a lot of movie
sets yeah uh if you could sneak on to
any of Steven's former movies and be a
fly on the wall which one would you
choose that's a tough one maybe one of
the Indiana Jones movies I think those
seem technically impressive and would
have been incredible to see the sets are
humongous there's a lot of miniature I
love miniature work I'm very fascinating
with Miniatures I know they use a lot of
Miniatures in those especially in the
Temple of Doom a lot of that uh the
little mining cart race was done with
Miniatures
um so yeah I would I would have gone and
watched that it's probably inspired by
the trains yeah there you go there you
go it's all coming together now once
you've seen this movie
um in getting sort of Benny down what
sort of was the most meaningful
conversation you had with Stephen in
terms of knowing who he was what did he
tell you about his relationship to the
Fable men's or his sort of essence
everyone I talked to who knew
Uncle Bernie Bernie is known the real
character is Bernie and my character is
Benny
um but the real guy was Uncle Bernie
um and everyone who knew him who my
character is very much inspired by um
yeah they would kind of light up and he
was so funny and so fun so nice so
lovely which very charismatic which is
hot you know which is like a tall order
every time I heard that I'm like oh God
like um because I'm none of those things
but it was uh yeah and so I really got
that this guy needed to be someone who
given what happens in the film
you liked him and you were supportive of
what happened in the film you understood
that he was a good guy that he was a a
genuinely fun loving guy because that is
from like a story standpoint actually
very like integral to why I think you
are happy kind of with what happens in
the film and why it's a a happy movie
ultimately and not a sad movie you know
and I think like
um yeah so I I understood honestly
from like a plot mechanics standpoint
what the character had to be in order to
make the movie function and so those
were the conversations as him just
really explained like yeah the character
has to be
lovable fun charismatic loose light
Charming energetic
um
yeah which uh yeah which honestly that
was yeah I understood it I I like I I
understood the assignment as they say
and so I I just had to try to do it
which is much harder than understanding
it
you definitely understood the assignment
and you nailed it
um I want to talk a little bit about The
Ensemble aspect of this film yeah the
fact that you're working with Michelle
and Paul and I think it was you and
maybe Paul said that the camping
sequences or really where it really
gelled yeah described that that sense of
camaraderie and that that Ensemble feel
because it really is they're great
performances by everybody yeah it really
and yeah the the girls and Gabe
um you know it
yeah it's something that like I really
like as an actor it's like when you feel
like you're a part of a team or if you I
I'm not a musician it's but what I
assume what it feels like to be in a
band a good band you know
um where every you you you feel that
maybe even though if you're not like
leading the charge in that moment you're
playing a role that's keeping the whole
thing afloat you know and and it's very
validating you support other people and
then they support you and and you know I
was very nervous when I I got cast but
honestly one of the one of the first
major alleviations of those nerves was
hearing that they cast Michelle and Paul
um because I've made a movie with
Michelle before and I just she's like
truly like a freakishly good actor like
and and it makes it really easy when
you're um working with someone who's
that good like they do a lot of the work
like and and I honestly there is some
like
very nuanced scenes involving uh my
character and that character and as soon
as i s I was nervous about it and then
as soon as I heard it was her I was like
it'll be fine like we'll we'll get them
it'll be easy like and and it will
largely because be because she's so good
my last question
out of the theme of this
versus what you become what sort of gave
you Seth the gestaltz to become an
artist
my parents were always very supportive
you know um and they
really treated it seriously when I
wanted to do comedy and
um act and make movies like yeah like I
started doing comedy when I was like 13
years old and my mother drove me to like
every comedy performance I ever did and
and was
and would hang out and became friends
with the comedians it would would help
facilitate me doing comedy you know
um
they signed me up for a workshop that's
like the first thing I ever really did
you know that kind of made me start
writing uh comedy when I was like 12 or
13 you know so they were very supportive
and
really
conversely my writing partner Evan his
parents were very unsupportive and I
really see like my parents were really
doing the heavy lifting for both of like
like if my parents were also
unsupportive we probably would have
stopped you know
um because I think there's only so much
discouragement that so many that people
can take and uh so yeah it was really uh
yeah I really looked back and I I thank
God they were so supportive she should
have been a concert piano player but she
got in her heart is what you got
family hot
it'll tear you into congratulations the
film your performance is incredible
um I'm wondering for you
um you play somebody that gives
Gabriel's character advice about being
fearless and going into Show Business
and I know that you originally were
going to be an engineer before you
became an actor did somebody give you
that advice or what gave you the
gestalts to become an artist
the same thing the character I play did
to him he said
art is a drug within him and he knew
that the kid had the same drug
and
that he he would never be able to kill
that instinct in himself he will suffer
but it'll but he'll suffer but but but
that's what's going to happen because
you can't kill it because it's going to
make you who you are you're not going to
be able to deny it it's one of those
things the word is art
and if you want to say it's about
acting's about painting it's about music
it's about that's the one and that's the
job that I had as an actor doing this
character to bring forth uh I mean it
was written that art is the true center
of the scene okay
it's going to hopefully Carries On
Through the movie in in various ways
but this guy is going to be out of
bounds and from somewhere right I didn't
say this to to Stephen I I said it seems
like an oracle has somehow come into
this room
and my confusion was I am
looking like I'm destroying a boy
you know
or making his life that's right he of
course the only thing he ever told me
was it changed his life the man changed
his life and that was the whole the
whole reason to have the same
is a moment in a man's life is what of
course the movie is right yeah the
moments of his life this was one which
changed
because he wasn't going to do this
anymore he was gonna and this guy came
at the right time
and told him in effect
he will suffer
and has to you just inspired me I'm
gonna change my life now
um one thing I do know is I believe you
you actually directed Stephen
one of the scenes Stephen talked about
how you said no the camera should be
over here and he actually took care of
advice no there was there was a moment
because
um one of the most important things in
the movies is that Stephen's mother
played the piano
and she was she should have been a
concert pianist but she didn't she
couldn't family in a way forced her not
to do the thing that art said to do okay
so this guy because he had to do it
himself and get out and move and leave
his family to do it
um
recognize that that she didn't do it so
in the so he he's trying to tell her son
you know she should have done it
I was angry should have done it gotta
choose an emotion right
what is it uh if I'm going to come
across You by telling you how important
this is to you
and and your mother didn't do it you
know you got a choice but feeling sorry
for her or uh not blaming her or
whatever no so you changed how did you
change the scene then like how did you
change well no so he said oh so I knew
she was a a Pianist a really good one
and she plays in in in the movie
so it was important thing in in Steven's
life that this mother of his was so good
in our scene we hear the piano playing
she's playing down the hall
you're playing in in the living room and
he said do you want to hear it
I said yes we give me an earpiece so I
can listen to the music about because
I'm about to say wait a minute right
and the scene was I would just say wait
a minute and stand there and listen and
finally I thought oh man this is too
good this is much too good
this is gonna this is gonna affect me
and how how I know
open the door I look out and because
it's coming from down the hall and so I
said I said um could I just
could you just do a single line maybe
you open the door and just see me
listening to it
because you know because I said wait a
minute
right he said
yeah
and it's in the movie
and then if in about five seconds
can we put a camera out there okay can
we light it yeah okay yes
and you're like congratulations Steve
and I've just directed you no I think
I think he would have done it
I think he would have he would he would
come around to do it it's just that I I
wasn't sure you know that uh
if you link in with the kind of guy he
is if you link in with his kind of
Direction which is don't pay attention
with anything else except what we're
doing you know about what you're what
you're saying and and the effect on the
other actor
um you have to be very aware about
what's happening to you
you know you're not just an Implement in
a room
I wasn't an oracle I didn't come from
nowhere so here comes reality pers two
people and uh I had to know the effect
that I was having on on this guy the
whole scene is what is he's trying to
have a great effect
historic effect right that's why that's
why it's in the movie and uh so that was
my obligation I'm thinking how do I make
this happen how
how am I gonna change this guy
Uncle comes from nowhere
I think we all had one when the family
got in trouble my mother's brother came
one time and said this is what you're
going to do I said what he said no no
listen to me
I thought he was an intruder my mother's
brother in my real life wow so yeah
there's always one of those guys I
wanted to ask you Stephen A young Steve
that's his so long
changes the course of his life what was
that movie for you oh The Greatest Show
on Earth no it was the movie for you
that you saw when you were young that
set your soul on fire and made you want
to be an actor oh
oh my God I'm gonna have to go back too
much too long
um two movies that I probably didn't
even like later you know because I
watched the acting you know what I'm
saying and I and I watch TCM a lot and
and takes me back to all the movies that
I've seen in the 40s and 50s because I'm
a guy from the 50s and uh they they of
course whether he was my inspiration and
all this kind of stuff and I watched the
movies and I go like this
oh
that's not acting I hate asking this
would you ever do it with yourself do
you ever do it with your own films like
do you ever watch yourself or do you
look and you critique yourself yeah
yeah yeah
um
it's a you know you you got to be me you
know the believability part is that I
know
when you should believe me and when you
and when you should question it all
right I think every actor could say that
but they probably won't
um
no it's uh it's it's tough some people
have a very tough time watching
themselves in the movies for their own
reasons you know Michelle Williams won't
watch her movies wow okay I understand
that Catherine Hepburn wouldn't watch
her own movies well
I don't know whether they have uh it
makes them self-conscious when they when
they have to do another one or to think
about what they've done and to change it
in their mind to me I can understand
someone saying oh damn I wish I would
have done what what the better shot you
know
yeah that's the bad part about that's
the bad part about movies and plays you
can you can change it every day okay in
movies you can't get they go that and
you go oh which one are you going to use
never mind and then you see it
you know you might remember a better
shot this one I didn't this one I knew
that every single shot was
um
very acceptable to Stephen well I know I
didn't give you any notes like he kind
of you did a scene and he just kind of
looked at you
yeah I was
I don't know ringing the right Bells
and uh but not by myself
this there's the guy I'm I'm and
sneakily I'm going with this is that
right is that okay yeah
um you mean Stephen yeah oh you were
and waves me off
you know he goes on to something else
goes on to the kid
goes on to the scenery because what the
sh the the objective is going to shoot
I'm thinking okay okay I'll walk with
that in other words we're present tense
all the time we're not going to go over
anything we're not going to reshoot
anything We're not gonna say I got a
better idea
well he knows what he's going to shoot
because this is this is different this
is a bio I mean this is in his life yeah
it's different uh it's not a bio it's um
and inspired
lifetime
of memory
as if played in the present
did you the scene where you're getting
into the car and you're saying goodbye
I'll never forget that look or that
gesture do you remember only enough we
shot that first I had no idea
what I was going to do to make that
happen
I'm not kidding I did I didn't know what
we had to because I guess it was
location or something like that and I
was they were ready for location
uh exterior of the house
and so when we did it
I had read the script by then but we
didn't we didn't we never discussed
anything about the the actual scene that
I was going to have with the kid finally
all we knew was that was the result
and you play a result first you go
okay okay I was guessing I was really
guessing but what what why how does that
how did I leave these people well
they're all
you know because when I saw it they were
scared to begin with they were they were
frightened of the of what was going to
happen because of something in in the
past that I did to her mother you know
and there they were all standing there
almost saying
isn't he something